Salut, moi c'est Guillaume Hachez. Bienvenue dans Septante Minutes Avec. Cette semaine, je passe septante minutes avec une invitée très spéciale puisqu'il s'agit de Charlotte Bellière qui est prof de français dans une école DASPA.
DASPA, ça veut dire Dispositif d'Accueil et de Scolarisation des Élèves Primo-arrivants. Autrement dit, quand une jeune Syrienne ou un jeune Roumain arrive en Belgique et qu'il s'inscrit à l'école,
il arrive dans une école DASPA comme celle de Charlotte.
Je n'ai pas l'habitude de faire ça, mais exceptionnellement, je vais être cash. Cet épisode numéro quatorze est très clairement un de mes préférés et j'espère qu'il vous plaira aussi.
Entre deux invités VIP comme le directeur de Google Belgique ou de Pure FM, j'aime bien aussi donner la parole à des intervenants moins connus et je pense que j'ai fait une très bonne pioche avec Charlotte.
Voilà, on se retrouve en fin de podcast pour un débrief. Let's go ! Et bonjour à tous. On est aujourd'hui avec Charlotte Bellière.
Charlotte Bellière, bonjour.
Bonjour.
Est-ce que tu peux te présenter pour nos auditeurs qui ne te connaissent pas ?
Oui, est-ce que tu veux que je me présente comme mes élèves se présentent ?
Comme tu le sens.
Alors, nos élèves, en fait, très vite, ils savent se présenter et donc ça donne à peu près ça : bonjour, je m'appelle Charlotte Bellière, j'ai trente-sept ans,
je suis Belge, je viens de Belgique, je parle français, un peu néerlandais et un peu anglais et j'habite à Bruxelles.
C'est magnifique, mais tu n'as pas dit ce que tu faisais dans la vie, donc nos auditeurs sont toujours confus.
Voilà, donc si vous voulez des précisions, je suis
professeur de français dans un DASPA.
Donc ça veut dire que je donne cours de français à des étrangers, à des élèves qui ne parlent pas ou très peu la langue, dans une école qui s'appelle le Campus Saint-Jean à Molenbeek et c'est une école secondaire.
Tu es prof depuis combien d'années en DASPA ?
Je pense que c'est ma neuvième année.
Neuvième année, OK. Tu étais prof avant ça dans une école classique-
Oui
...ou jamais ?
Tout à fait classique.
Qu'est-ce qui t'a menée, en fait, à, voilà, faire ce switch, à passer de prof de français classique à prof de français langue étrangère ?
Ben d'abord, c'est ma formation, en fait. Donc moi, j'ai fait un régendat en français, français langue étrangère, donc les deux options.
Et quand on est en première année de régendat, on va visiter ce qu'on appelait à l'époque des classes passerelles.
Donc, sagement, avec mon petit groupe, j'avais été visiter des classes passerelles à Bruxelles et j'avais trouvé ça super.
J'avais trouvé ça complètement dingue, mais j'avais vraiment trouvé ça super. Et
j'avais trouvé ça d'autant plus super que mes études ne me passionnaient pas vraiment, que j'étais un peu là, pas par hasard, mais pas super contente d'être là.
Sans conviction, hein.
Voilà. Et il a vraiment fallu attendre mes gros stages de deuxième et de troisième pour que je sente que donner cours à des ados, c'était vraiment mon truc.
Mais donner cours à des ados primo-arrivants ?
Pas spécialement.
Non, pas spécialement, OK.
Non, non, non. Vraiment, le stage qui m'a vraiment confirmé que c'était mon truc, c'était un stage en professionnel, donc public fragilisé aussi, mais voilà.
Donc j'ai terminé mes études en étant très contente d'avoir terminé des études et en étant sûre que c'était prof que je voulais faire.
Et puis après, j'ai postulé dans les écoles des environs. J'ai travaillé un an à Wavre, c'était super. Et puis j'ai travaillé trois ans à Gembloux, dans un grand collège traditionnel.
Mh.
Et c'était très chouette aussi. Donc là, j'ai fait beaucoup de classes, j'ai fait des deuxièmes, des troisièmes, des techniques de qualification, donc j'ai vraiment varié.
Mais à un moment donné, j'avais vraiment envie d'aventure, envie d'alternatif et je me suis rappelée de ces classes de dingues que j'avais été visiter.
Pourquoi est-ce que tu les appelles les classes de dingues ?
Mais parce que ça ne ressemblait en rien à ce que moi, j'avais connu en tant qu'élève et je me suis beaucoup ennuyée à l'école.
Et venant de Wavre et ayant fait mes études à Louvain-la-Neuve, moi, j'étais très peu confrontée à une population étrangère, donc ça m'avait semblé un peu une autre planète, mais justement, c'est ça qui m'intéressait.
Et voilà. Et donc j'ai senti que c'était le moment. Et donc j'ai démissionné d'abord de ce collège en expliquant ma démarche, en effrayant un petit peu les gens autour de moi, parce que ça semblait vraiment très très bizarre.
D'accord.
Parce que donc, je venais de postuler au campus Saint-Jean de Molenbeek.
Oui, donc tu passes de Gembloux à Molenbeek et ça, les gens-
Oui, non, les gens ont pas du tout compris. Pas du tout. Enfin, certaines personnes, oui, mais en tout cas, les gens avec qui j'ai travaillé à Gembloux, ça a été quand même très très-
Ce qui est intéressant dans ce que tu racontes, c'est que, 'fin d'habitude, en tout cas, c'est mon impression, les profs sont ceux qui sont premier rang, qui notent tout, qui sont très studieux quand ils sont à l'école.
Et puis ils adorent l'école et donc quand on leur demande ce qu'ils veulent faire dans la vie : « Je veux devenir prof, je veux retourner à l'école.
» Et toi, tu dis : « J'ai pas du tout aimé ça-
Non
...mais je suis quand même devenue prof. »
Ah oui, oui, ça, c'est complètement dingue. Encore. Oui, oui, oui, oui, mais ben oui, j'étais pas une très bonne élève, dans les résultats plutôt moyennes, mais
assez, 'fin, je bavardais beaucoup, j'étais plutôt rebelle, l'autorité, c'était vraiment pas mon truc, je faisais un peu de provocation.
'Fin bon. Donc... Et c'est surtout que, 'fin, je ne comprenais pas le sens des mathématiques. Pourquoi apprendre les mathématiques ?
Je ne le comprenais pas. Maintenant, je le comprends un peu mieux parce que j'ai vieilli. Mais sur le moment, faire quelque chose qui n'avait pas de sens, c'était très difficile pour moi.
C'est vraiment ça le-
C'était le côté dogmatique, rigide, strict, inquestionnable de l'école qui-
Devoir rentrer dans le moule, ça, c'était dur. Et dans le collège traditionnel dans lequel j'ai commencé à travailler, c'est ce qu'on m'a demandé.
C'est vraiment une curiosité que tu te sois retrouvée là-bas alors que tu détestais ça quoi.
En fait, ma vocation, c'est d'être prof, peu importe le public que j'ai. Je serais contente avec n'importe quel public. Pour le moment, je travaille avec les étrangers, mais je ne dis pas que ce sera toute la vie.
Donc voilà, les adolescents, c'est les adolescents quoi.
Et quoi, et tu estimes, 'fin, on va pas passer des heures à parler de Jean Plouh, mais
est-ce que tu estimes que quand tu étais prof là-bas, de par ta nature un peu plus rebelle, comme tu dis, un peu moins dogmatique, un peu moins, voilà, prof-
Tradi.
Tradi, oui. Est-ce que t'estimes que tu donnais cours de manière fondamentalement différente par rapport à tes collègues ?
Tu étais tradi toi-même ?
Non, j'étais pas très tradi.
J'étais très motivée, j'étais passionnée, j'avais envie d'essayer plein de trucs, mais j'étais dans une grosse machine et donc, voilà, je devais quand même un petit peu me conformer-
Mh.
À ce qui était mis en place avant moi. C'est des grosses équipes, hein, donc voilà. Et ça, je respecte beaucoup.
Mais donc à un moment donné, j'ai eu envie de plus de liberté. Et ça, dans ce genre de boîte, c'est difficile. Et moi, je me suis sentie serrée.
Voilà, donc tu as fait ta transition, tu es devenue prof de français langue étrangère pour élèves DASPA. DASPA, ça veut dire dispositif d'accueil et de scolarité pour primo-arrivants.
Oui.
Les élèves qui arrivent chez toi, ils viennent d'où exactement ?
Bah du monde entier.
Partout, partout ?
Ouais, partout. Non, oui. J'ai peut-être pas eu tous les pays du monde. Mais oui, oui, ils viennent de partout.
On a évidemment des réfugiés de guerre, des demandeurs d'asile, on a des mineurs non accompagnés, mais on a aussi des familles qui fuient, ben la misère.
Et la misère, elle peut être n'importe où. Donc, voilà.
Est-ce qu'il y a des nationalités qui sont peut-être plus représentées que d'autres ?
Oui, oui, ben nous, on est situés à Molenbeek, donc à Molenbeek, y a quand même une grande communauté marocaine.
Mh.
Donc, on a quand même pas mal de Marocains. Alors, depuis quelques années-
Les Marocains, a priori, ils parlent français ?
Disons que la langue est enseignée là-bas, mais non, ils ne parlent pas français. Ils ne parlent pas tous français couramment.
Ils ont eu des cours de français, mais là aussi, 'fin y a du boulot quand même.
Et c'est quoi finalement la différence dans l'organisation d'une classe DASPA par rapport à une classe classique ?
Le nombre d'heures de français, déjà. Donc les élèves d'une classe DASPA ont un cours de français de quinze heures par semaine, quinze à dix-sept heures même, ça dépend des classes.
Alors que normalement, c'est plutôt quatre ?
C'est quatre à cinq heures, ouais, oui. Donc, voilà, ça, c'est une grande différence. Après, ils ont d'autres cours aussi.
Ils ont des maths, des sciences, de l'étude du milieu, du sport, de l'art. Donc voilà. Mais chaque cours est donné dans l'idée de les remettre à niveau dans la langue.
Donc le cours de sciences, oui, bien sûr, ils font des sciences, mais surtout, ils font des sciences en français. Donc l'idée, c'est d'arriver à faire la correspondance entre, ben leur cours de sciences dans leur langue et,
et maintenant en français afin qu'ils puissent suivre quand ils réintégreront le circuit normal.
À l'échelle de la Belgique, les élèves primo-arrivants comme ça, qui ne parlent pas le français, sont nombreux.
Il y en a combien à peu près ?
En fait, d'après un article du Ligueur-
D'accord.
Sorti il y a pas longtemps-
Uh huh.
Il y aurait plus ou moins deux mille primo-arrivants-
À l'échelle de la Belgique ?
À l'échelle de la Belgique, en primaire et en secondaire. Ça, c'est les chiffres que j'ai pu lire dans le Ligueur.
Après, c'est ma seule source. Donc, à vérifier peut-être. Mais ça-
Y en a combien chez toi ?
Chez moi, il y en a quarante-huit.
D'accord. Donc, tu as un bon pourcentage.
Ouais, un bon pourcentage. Mais quarante-huit en secondaire. Mais par contre, 'fin, ça, c'est les élèves qui sont dans un DASPA, mais il y a beaucoup d'autres élèves qui ne parlent pas la langue et qui ne sont pas dans un DASPA.
Donc, c'est ça.
Mh. Oui, on pourra peut-être revenir là-dessus, mais y a moi-même, quand j'étais en secondaire, y avait des élèves italiens qui sont arrivés au milieu d'année, voilà, qui parlaient pas français, mais qui ont dû s'adapter.
Et ça, ça marchait pas trop mal.
T'étais en quelle année secondaire ? Tu étais en quelle année ?
C'était deux sœurs. Il y en avait une qui est arrivée en cinquième secondaire et l'autre en quatrième.
Mais quelle année ? En 1990-
Ah.
Ou en 2000 ?
Tu me demandes mon âge ?
Oui, je te demande ton âge.
Non, non.
T'es pas obligé de répondre, mais les-
Y a pas de souci.
Les classes passerelles, en fait, existent depuis 2000.
Oh bah oui, non, je suis pas si vieux, je suis pas si vieux que ça. C'était en 2010, à peu près.
Oui, ben voilà. Ben donc, il existait déjà des classes passerelles.
Oui.
Et tu avais quand même des-
C'est ça.
Des personnes ne parlant pas la langue. Et ça va, ça a été ?
Bah oui, oui.
Elles se sont, elles s'en sont bien sorties ?
Il y en a une que je connais qui étudie la médecine à Louvain.
Super.
Voilà, bah oui. Ouais, donc tu as répondu pour le nombre d'élèves à l'échelle de la Belgique, voilà, selon le Ligueur.
Et le nombre d'écoles, le nombre d'établissements en Belgique et en, voilà, en Fédération Wallonie-Bruxelles pour répondre à ces vagues d'élèves primo-arrivants-
Je pense-
Est-ce qu'il y en a assez ?
Qu'il y a septante-cinq DASPA en Fédération Wallonie-Bruxelles, primaire et secondaire.
D'accord. Donc ça fait une moyenne de ? Bah à peu près-
Je te rappelle que pour moi, les maths n'ont pas de sens.
Une petite trentaine d'élèves par établissement alors.
Non, non, parce qu'en fait, tous les DASPA s'organisent comme ils veulent. Et donc nous, par exemple, on a quarante-huit élèves dans notre DASPA, quarante-huit élèves divisés en quatre classes, mais
une école peut avoir un DASPA constitué d'une seule classe ou un autre de deux classes.
Enfin voilà, je n'ai aucune idée de la répartition. Ce que je peux dire par rapport à la répartition, c'est qu'il y a quasiment autant de DASPA en Wallonie qu'à Bruxelles.
D'accord.
C'est très concentré à Bruxelles.
Est-ce qu'il arrive que, voilà, on parlait donc de deux mille à l'échelle de la Belgique, est-ce qu'il arrive que certains ne trouvent pas de place ?
Ben, je n'en sais rien. Je connais notre fonctionnement, donc je sais que nous, on se limite à quarante-huit, ce qui est déjà pas mal.
Et qu'après, quand il y a des élèves qui viennent pour s'inscrire, notre coordinateur les renvoie à d'autres DASPA.
Et voilà, je ne sais pas si tout le monde trouve de la place. On n'a pas vraiment de vue là-dessus.
Et voilà, et donc ceux qui arrivent, en tout cas dans ton établissement, quand ils arrivent et qu'ils parlent pas du tout français, comment ça se passe pour leur donner cours s'ils comprennent rien ?
Ça se passe bien. On s'amuse bien.
Donc c'est quoi ? C'est le langage des signes, on fait des jeux, on essaye de-
Oui, en effet. Donc déjà au tout début, on fonctionne beaucoup par répétition. Donc on ne va jamais leur demander : « Quel âge as-tu ?
» Mais on va plutôt dire : « J'ai trente-sept ans et toi ? » Donc vraiment, qu'ils s'approprient des structures très simples et-
Comme ça, ils ont déjà une idée de la réponse, la structure de la réponse qu'ils doivent donner. Oui, oui, c'est intéressant.
Donc la répétition, dans tous les sens, de toutes les manières, ça, on l'utilise beaucoup. Ensuite, quand on a des invités, des observateurs en classe, ils nous trouvent toujours
très marrants parce que notre manière de donner cours est plutôt physique et assez théâtrale.
D'accord.
Par exemple, en début d'année, on aborde vite les émotions, pouvoir exprimer les émotions. Ça, ça nous semble essentiel.
Et les émotions, il faut bien les faire comprendre, donc il faut les mimer. Donc voilà, pour apprendre à être content, être triste, je les mime, et puis il les mime, et puis on répète.
Et tout ça dans une bonne ambiance fait qu'assez vite, il maîtrise une bonne base de vocabulaire.
Ça, c'est au niveau linguistique. Et après, après combien de temps est-ce que, voilà, ils commencent à s'en sortir, à savoir parler, peut-être pas comme toi et moi, mais un bon niveau de français ?
Mais en fait, ça dépend parce que ça dépend du profil. Ça dépend d'abord du profil d'élève et puis ça dépend parfois de chaque élève.
Les profils des élèves plus scolarisés, on peut dire qu'à Noël, on peut tenir une conversation, bien sûr, avec pas mal de fautes et pas toujours le vocabulaire dont ils ont besoin, mais on se débrouille.
Franchement, on se débrouille assez bien.
Ça correspond à l'expérience que j'ai eue, donc, avec, voilà, avec mes deux Italiennes. Oui, ça, c'est tout à fait... Après quelques mois, ça allait.
Oui.
Donc, il y a d'autres profils où-
Ah oui, après, enfin, on a quand même vraiment une bonne partie de nos élèves qui sont peu ou pas scolarisés, qui n'ont jamais été scolarisés ou qui ont été scolarisés de manière chaotique ou qui arrivent traumatisés.
Enfin, vraiment des profils très fragilisés. Et ces élèves-là, à Noël, oui, on peut parler avec eux, mais nous, on peut peut-être les comprendre, mais toi, je suis pas sûre que tu les comprends.
Ça, c'est alors plutôt, voilà, comme tu disais, les élèves fragilisés, peut-être réfugiés, qui ont connu la guerre.
Oui, oui, c'est ça. Ben, en fait, donc
comme je disais, chez nous, dans notre DASPA, on a quatre classes et, parmi ces quatre classes, il y a une classe de non alphabétisés, donc des élèves qui n'ont quasiment jamais été à l'école ou pas du tout.
Et ces élèves doivent apprendre à lire et à écrire, à parler français. Et on a une deuxième classe qui, d'une année à l'autre, c'est la classe de laquelle je suis titulaire, peut varier au niveau du profil des élèves.
Soit c'est une classe de petits scolarisés, donc comme ils sont assez jeunes, ils ont douze ans, treize ans, ils n'ont pas été très loin dans leur parcours scolaire.
Donc il y a quand même beaucoup de travail, mais ils sont scolarisés. Ou alors c'est le public plus fragilisé, pas spécialement des non alphabétisés, mais des faibles lecteurs, des faibles scripteurs.
Et là, ça prend plus de temps.
C'est-à-dire à peu près ? Deux ans ou quatre ans ?
Mais ça dépend quel objectif, en fait. Si, enfin... Parfois, après deux ans, c'est toujours difficile de les comprendre, même s'ils ne sont plus dans le DASPA.
Parce qu'on ne pouvait pas les garder deux ans. Donc, ils intègrent le système classique, mais non, parfois, on n'arrive toujours pas bien à les comprendre après deux ans.
Et donc,
on parle ici, voilà, de l'aspect qui est le tien, donc l'enseignement du français. Mais voilà, quand on parle de réfugiés, quand on parle de gens qui arrivent de Syrie, qui ont connu la guerre, des jeunes enfants,
est-ce qu'il y a un travail aussi au niveau psychologique, un travail au niveau humain de-
C'est-
Est-ce que tu remarques que ces gens-là, au niveau du contact social, sont, on va dire, différents ? Pour ne pas orienter la réponse.
Oui, ben en fait, en 2015, on a vraiment reçu la vague de Syrie en pleine figure.
Et... enfin, si on doit l'exprimer, on a vraiment vu des fantômes arriver, donc des élèves traumatisés, chacun réagissant à sa manière.
On avait des élèves,
qui étaient complètement mutiques, donc incapables d'apprendre. On avait aussi d'autres élèves qui n'étaient pas du tout mutiques, qui découvraient un monde en paix, les dauphins, les licornes-
Ah oui
...enfin, vraiment-
Le paradis, ouais
...mais par contre, qui n'apprenaient pas du tout non plus, donc bloqués dans leur apprentissage, très fort.
Trop distraits, trop perturbés par le changement de paysage.
Voilà, trop perturbés par le changement et pas du tout, enfin, en train d'apprendre une-
C'est ça
...langue, pas encore prêts à ça. Et donc là, on a vraiment cherché des solutions parce que nous, on a morflé-
Mmh
...psychologiquement aussi, parce que quand tu es vingt heures par semaine avec des élèves chargés comme ça en émotions, ben, ça n'a pas été facile.
On a toutes eu dur cette année-là. Et donc on a cherché de l'aide et on en a trouvé.
On en a trouvé notamment auprès du centre de santé mentale Exil, qui ont bien voulu collaborer avec nous, nous écouter, et collaborer avec nos élèves.
Et donc, deux super psys d'Exil ont mis en place une animation qui parle de l'exil et qui explique, il y a plein de manières de gérer ces émotions très fortes liées à cet exil.
Et en fait, cette activité a été salutaire pour les Syriens, mais on a constaté qu'elle était essentielle pour un Espagnol, pour un Roumain, pour n'importe quel élève, parce que,
bien sûr, les réfugiés de guerre, c'est très spectaculaire, mais finalement, la souffrance,
la souffrance d'un Brésilien qui a quitté sa maman pour arriver ici dans la famille de son papa, son papa qui est là déjà depuis dix ans, donc il n'a plus vu son papa depuis dix ans.
Le papa s'est remarié, a des enfants ici qui parlent tous français. La détresse de cet adolescent-là peut vraiment engendrer des blocages.
Et voilà, et donc le travail en réponse à ça, c'est un travail par les psychologues ou bien c'est aussi, voilà, de ton côté, au niveau de l'enseignant ?
Alors, c'est d'abord avant tout un travail de psychologue et nous, on n'est pas psychologues-
Mmh
...donc, on a cette activité avec Exil. Depuis cette année, on a la chance d'avoir une psychologue du centre PMS de l'école qui est là pour nous.
Donc elle n'est pas là tout le temps, mais en tout cas, elle se spécialise sur ce type de profil. Donc, voilà, ça se met en place aussi, mais parce qu'on a vraiment demandé, demandé, demandé, alerté.
Et puis alors, au quotidien, nous, on fait un gros travail, on fait un gros travail de soutien parce que moi je suis titulaire de la classe et je les ai treize heures par semaine.
Et donc c'est un peu comme une famille, 'fin, c'est mes enfants. Et on les entoure de beaucoup de bienveillance, de patience.
Et je pense que ça, pour certains élèves, c'est un sas essentiel quand ils arrivent.
Ouais.
Qu'il dure six mois, qu'il dure un an et parfois qu'il dure plus longtemps.
Donc là, là-dessus, voilà, tu parles de ce sas. Est-ce qu'il arrive que les élèves quittent ce sas, se dirigent dans le circuit classique et que tu estimes que la mission n'a pas été accomplie ?
Bien sûr.
Tu estimes-
Oui, oui
...comme quand, par exemple ?
Ben, pour le moment, le décret prévoit dix-huit mois
de DASPA. Alors, c'est super parce que donc concrètement, ça fait qu'un élève arrivant au mois de septembre, il reste avec nous jusqu'au mois de juin et puis on estime qu'il est pas prêt, qu'il est pas prêt à passer.
Et donc cet élève, on aimerait le garder. Mais sauf que les écoles sont saturées et les directeurs ne veulent pas garder des places dans les classes traditionnelles.
'Fin, chez nous, on a de la chance. Notre directeur nous garde quelques petites places, mais c'est rare. Et donc, si on garde notre élève dix-huit mois, ça fait qu'au mois de février, mars de l'année suivante, il n'a pas de classe.
Donc, 'fin, je sais pas si tu comprends, c'est peut-être-
Oui
...plus technique, mais c'est aberrant.
Chose musicale.
Oui, voilà.
Ouais, ouais. Donc là, ça, c'est un niveau de, voilà, un niveau de-
Et ça n'encourage pas à les garder parce que c'est pas pratique.
Oui.
Donc il arrive qu'on renvoie, on lâche des élèves pas prêts dans le circuit-
Quand tu dis pas prêts, donc tu parles strictement au niveau de maîtrise du français ?
Maîtrise du français-
Ou bien est-ce que tu parles aussi de ce que tu évoquais plus tôt, c'est-à-dire l'accompagnement, la détresse, tout ce qui est plutôt au niveau psychologique ?
Il arrive que vous lâchiez, entre guillemets, un élève ?
Pas adapté, tu veux dire ?
Ben, pas adapté, peut-être, oui, ou encore un petit peu en détresse.
Oui, mais s'il reste dans l'école, nous, vu qu'on a un gros DASPA, les années suivantes sont spécialisées aussi.
Donc, on a une première et une deuxième commune, donc générale, spécialisée pour nos élèves. Donc, ils sont aussi pris en charge.
Il y a un petit peu plus de français et les élèves sont un peu plus attentifs. On a une troisième et une quatrième aussi, FLE.
Donc l'équipe qui travaille là-dedans est attentive à ce type de profil. Et alors, on a aussi une super équipe dans le différencié et en professionnel, qui sait ce qui arrive.
Donc, on n'est pas les seuls-
D'accord
...à être très attentifs.
Ouais.
Toute notre école est sensibilisée. Ou si tout le monde ne l'est pas, il devrait.
Oui. Et donc, dans le cas des élèves qui, voilà, qui sont ici avec leur famille, avec leurs parents, comment se passe le contact avec les parents, justement, qui eux-mêmes, sans doute, ne maîtrisent pas le français ?
Non, non, non, non, non, les parents ne maîtrisent pas le français et très vite, en fait, les enfants deviennent un peu les chefs de famille et gèrent l'administratif, ben, parfois mieux que les parents.
Nous, on a des contacts avec les parents, 'fin, comme on a comme objectif aussi d'acclimater l'élève à la vie en Belgique et au système scolaire, ben, ça implique aussi d'acclimater les parents.
Donc, par exemple, on a une grande réunion d'information où on invite les parents et on explique le système scolaire, et on rencontre les parents en début d'année.
Mais on a aussi les réunions de parents classiques, où on rend le bulletin. Et donc, là, il y a moi qui rends le bulletin, il y a l'élève qui reçoit son bulletin et les parents ainsi qu'un interprète. Parce que-
D'accord, un interprète-
Oui, voilà
...qui, voilà, qui est financé-
Par l'école.
D'accord.
Juste par l'école.
OK.
Bien gentiment. Et c'est du budget. Donc, mais c'est indispensable. Sans ça, les parents ne comprennent pas.
Vous ne comptez pas sur l'enfant pour traduire ce bulletin-
Non, on ne compte pas sur l'enfant. Ça peut arriver, mais alors dans ces cas-là, on est vraiment désolé et on ne sait pas du tout ce qu'il raconte.
Oui, c'est ça. Oui, c'est ça. J'ai très bien travaillé. Oui. Et donc, en plus de la barrière de la langue, hein, on évoquait, voilà, l'aspect peut-être un peu plus psychologique, le trauma, etc.
Mais on imagine qu'il y a aussi une barrière culturelle. On en a un petit peu parlé avant, avant de démarrer l'interview, mais comment est-ce que ça peut se concrétiser, par exemple ?
Ben, alors, barrière de la langue, je comprends. On en a bien parlé. Barrière culturelle, en fait, barrière, c'est pas le bon mot-
D'accord
...parce que la culture, c'est jamais une barrière et c'est toujours enrichissant. Donc
là où ça commence à devenir une barrière, c'est quand il y a plus d'hétérogénéité, il y a trop d'homogénéité dans les cultures.
Et pour illustrer, l'année passée, la classe de non alphabétisés chez nous était exclusivement syrienne. Donc chaque élève était syrien.
Il y avait des liens familiaux, il y avait deux fois deux frères, il y avait un cousin dans l'histoire. Donc, il y avait des liens familiaux.
Certains venaient de la même région, certains avaient les mêmes origines. 'Fin, donc tout ça était très entre soi, en fait.
Ouais.
Et ils n'ont jamais réussi à en sortir. Et les profs étaient exclus. Il y avait une telle homogénéité que, on en ressort moins de richesse, évidemment.
Et donc, dans ces cas-là, les élèves apprennent moins. Donc voilà, 'fin, c'est juste pour dire que-
Intéressant. Donc, ils sont arrivés ici avec leur, j'ai envie de dire, leur hiérarchie, leur-
Avec leurs codes.
Oui, c'est ça.
Dans une classe où il n'y a pas d'hétérogénéité, pardon, culturelle, les codes restent, en fait. Donc-
Oui
...ça peut être très difficile à vivre pour les profs et être un frein à l'apprentissage. Certains élèves mettent plus de temps à s'adapter aux coutumes de Belgique, aux codes ou je ne sais pas, et gardent en tout cas
les codes du pays.
Comment est-ce que ça se concrétise, par exemple ?
Voilà, ben, ces dernières années, on a eu une vague de bébés DASPA.
Bébés DASPA ?
Des bébés DASPA.
Très jeunes pour arriver en DASPA.
Ouais, mais on n'a pas donné cours aux bébés. Malheureusement, on a donné cours aux mamans.
D'accord.
Donc en fait, ce qui se passe, c'est qu'en arrivant, ben, ces filles sont dans le DASPA et les familles s'installent, mais gardent les coutumes du pays.
Et donc, dans certains pays, les filles sont mariées assez jeunes. Et donc, en fait,
on a eu des filles mariées religieusement, c'est interdit, mariées assez jeunes, 15 ans, 16 ans, 17 ans, et donc fatalement en couple et donc vite enceintes.
Et ça, ça nous a foutu un coup, hein, pour parler-
Un peu le bourdon ? Oui.
Ah oui, oui, c'était dur, hein. À chaque nouvelle annonce de grossesse, là, c'est... J'allais dire : « Ça s'est un peu calmé », mais non, il y a des jumeaux qui vont bientôt arriver et un autre bébé-
OK
...donc un petit frère. Voilà.
Quand ça s'est calmé, parce que... pas parce qu'il y en a moins, mais peut-être parce que vous, vous êtes habitués.
On commence à s'habituer. Oui, c'est peut-être ça, je sais pas.
Quand tu disais que ça vous mettait un peu le bourdon, d'où est-ce que ça vient, ça-
Ben, ça, ça vient du choc culturel-
Ouais.
...parce que tu parlais de barrière culturelle, mais ce mot-
Oui, tout à fait.
...me plaît pas trop. Mais par contre-
On peut parler d'un gouffre culturel.
Oui, oui, oui, oui, le choc culturel est rude. 'Fin, je veux dire, moi, j'ai 37 ans, j'ai eu mes enfants à 30 ans.
C'était déjà fort tard pour ma famille, mais bon, voilà, j'ai fait comme j'ai pu. On n'a pas du tout les mêmes priorités.
C'est ça.
Et donc, il faut arriver à ne pas être dans le jugement, à faire de la prévention. Et ça, depuis la vague des bébés, on a vraiment aussi mis en place
d'autres choses pour faire de la prévention, et continuer à être, voilà, soutenant, accompagnant et pas dans le jugement, de ces filles qui, finalement,
ne nous renvoient pas du tout une image de victime.
Nous, on les voit comme des victimes, mais elles ne se sentent pas victimes. Elles se disent contentes, consentantes.
Quand tu parles de prévention, tu penses à quoi exactement ?
Je pense au travail formidable des plannings familiaux-
D'accord.
...qui font de l'éducation à la vie sexuelle et affective.
Oui.
Mais pour nos élèves, c'est... 'Fin, je crois que c'est de toute façon un travail compliqué et courageux. Mais quand
les responsables du planning familial se retrouvent devant tant de diversité culturelle, il faut arriver à trouver les mots justes, les mots clairs, parce qu'
il y a vraiment une méconnaissance du sujet, beaucoup de tabous et il faut un peu faire sauter tout ça quoi.
Oui, oui. Donc là, on est vraiment au cœur du gouffre culturel dont on parlait. Ça fait que j'ai envie de poser les questions sur, ben...
si on parle d'élèves syriens, peut-être un peu plus la religion, sur tout ce qui est égalité des sexes, tout ce qui est, voilà, leur relation avec la sexualité.
Comment est-ce que vous gérez ça exactement ? Bon, par exemple, on peut très bien imaginer
des élèves syriens qui ont en tête, culturellement, des rôles genrés très définis, un rôle de la femme très défini, un rôle de l'homme très défini.
Et puis, on arrive en Belgique et il faut peut-être un petit peu remettre ça en question ou comment ?
Ah oui, oui, bah évidemment. Ben, leur premier choc culturel à eux, c'est nous. Donc quand notre-
Le fait d'avoir un prof femme, ça les surprend ?
Un prof femme et puis très rapidement, ils comprennent que j'ai des enfants. Mais quand on voit les différents types de relations, ils comprennent que je ne suis pas mariée, donc ils s'étonnent.
Ils comprennent aussi que je n'ai pas de religion.
D'accord.
Et donc là, ils s'étonnent très, très, très, très fort.
Tu dis, ils s'étonnent. C'est vraiment de l'étonnement et de-
Oui.
...de la surprise ou bien il y a un petit peu de-
Ah, il y a un petit peu de cémal. Oui, oui, oui, il y a un petit peu de cémal, hein. Madame, je me rappelle d'une petite Djiboutienne de treize ans qui disait : « Quoi ?
T'as pas de religion, madame ? » Je dis : « Ben non, oui. Enfin, je sais pas, voilà. Enfin... » « Mais alors, tes yeux, madame, qui te les a donnés si c'est pas Dieu ? »
Ouh là là. Et là, qu'est-ce que tu réponds à ça ?
Je dis : « Bah, je sais pas. »
Mes parents.
Ben oui, ici, elle était très, très, très jeune et mon idée n'est pas du tout, avec des jeunes comme ça, de les bousculer durement.
Ce n'est pas du tout, c'est pas du tout la... Enfin, je pense que juste d'être confronté à ça va faire évoluer en douceur.
Elle va s'acclimater. Par contre, il est vrai que quand
un gaillard de quinze ans, quand on voit les activités de la journée et que je demande ce qu'il aime, ce qu'il n'aime pas et qu'on parle de faire la vaisselle et qu'il me fait : « Oh non, moi, je fais jamais la vaisselle ».
Bien sûr, là, je lui rentre dedans. Je lui dis : « Mais comment ça ? Tu sais qui fait la vaisselle chez moi ? » Et quand je lui dis que c'est mon compagnon, il ne revient pas.
Donc oui, oui. Mais tout ça est toujours dans la bonne humeur, en fait. Jamais dans-
Dans la confrontation.
Dans la confrontation dure. Parce qu'avec ces élèves, on a vraiment établi une relation de confiance très forte.
Et, ben voilà. Et puis, de toute façon, c'est pas dans mon tempérament de-
Non.
...de militer agressivement.
Et quand on pense à, voilà, d'autres chocs culturels qu'il pourrait y avoir, mais auxquels ils ne sont pas forcément confrontés, au sein de l'école ou autres.
Hein, j'avais noté ici, par exemple, l'homophobie, hein.
Oui.
Imaginons qu'il n'y ait pas de prof homosexuel, mais qu'ils arrivent quand même avec peut-être un certain bagage homophobe, selon là d'où ils viennent.
Est-ce que c'est quelque chose que vous essayez de désamorcer ou bien est-ce que, voilà, non ?
Si, bien sûr. Bien sûr qu'on essaie de désamorcer, on... Je pense que la valeur principale qu'on essaye de diffuser, c'est le respect et ce, dans tous les domaines.
Et l'homophobie est présente. Mais oui, c'est marrant parce que je pense à
la diversité culturelle à laquelle ils sont confrontés, parce qu'ils sont confrontés à nous, les professeurs belges, mais ils sont confrontés aussi à d'autres élèves des quatre coins du monde.
Et je pense à une anecdote rigolote où des élèves, je ne sais plus de quelle nationalité, étaient vraiment choqués parce que lors d'une sortie, deux garçons guinéens se donnaient la main.
D'accord.
Et en fait, enfin, évidemment, on entendait : « Gay, gay, gay, homosexuel, madame. » Et, mais doucement, ils ne l'ont pas dit suffisamment fort pour que les deux Guinéens l'entendent.
Donc, il y a déjà une retenue qui s'installe automatiquement, c'est déjà bien. Et-
Et c'était quoi ? C'était le choc brutal ou bien un peu en rigolant ?
Ah oui, très gênés, très gênés. Et puis pas choqués à être agressifs, loin de là, mais juste très gênés et ne comprenant pas du tout comment ces deux garçons osaient se donner la main.
C'est ça.
Ils nous ont vraiment signifié qu'ils pensaient qu'ils étaient homosexuels et nous leur avons rétorqué qu'en fait, non, ils étaient copains, mais que, ben visiblement, de là d'où ils venaient-
Ah oui, d'accord.
...c'était juste un signe amical, que sur la route vers une activité, les deux garçons se sont spontanément donné la main, voilà, par amitié.
Et donc, si tu devais faire un pari, tu dirais que ce jeune garçon qui était choqué de voir deux Guinéens se tenir par la main, quand il a quitté ta classe, il était parfaitement tolérant avec la sexualité ?
Ah non, bien sûr que non. Bien sûr que non. Enfin, c'est pas l'école qui fait tout changer non plus. Moi, je sais pas comment il est éduqué à la maison.
Je sais pas comment on lui parle. Et parfois, je peux imaginer, mais voilà. Non, bien sûr que non. Et tout ça, enfin, le combat contre l'homophobie, le combat pour faire avancer l'égalité des sexes, c'est très lent.
Et c'est un peu comme quand on apprend une langue, on doit répéter et répéter et répéter. Et là, on espère que si tous les canaux d'information s'y mettent, on espère que le franc tombe.
Voilà, j'apporte ma pierre à l'édifice-
Ouais.
Mais je n'ai absolument pas la prétention de faire changer un élève en un claquement de doigts.
Mais je sais que je suis confrontante de par ce que je suis.
Et donc répéter, répéter, répéter, tu estimes que tu le fais ?
Oui oui, bien sûr. On estime qu'on le fait parce que, en fait, notre programme de français est vraiment basé sur des compétences très pratico-pratiques et en Belgique.
Et donc, 'fin, très vite, on,
on leur explique les lois. Donc c'est vrai qu'on leur explique, on peut se marier entre personnes de même sexe, qu'en Belgique, les femmes ne restent pas spécialement à la maison.
'Fin pas toutes, ça arrive, mais... Donc bien sûr, on parle de tout ça librement.
Très bien. Est-ce qu'il y a d'autres situations de choc, de gouffre culturel auxquelles tu peux penser ?
Oui, mais, 'fin, j'ai des anecdotes moins marrantes. 'Fin, je pense à une-
C'est bien aussi.
Oui oui oui, bien sûr. Je pense à une réunion de parents, c'était ma deuxième année, donc j'avais moins d'expérience et, voilà.
Mais en fait, ça ne change rien. Quand t'as des tristes histoires comme ça, t'es toujours ébranlé.
Et donc, j'avais une petite élève pakistanaise, super, que j'aimais vraiment beaucoup, qui était très mignonne, mais très timide.
Et à la réunion de parents, donc comme j'ai expliqué tout à l'heure, réunion de parents avec interprète, élève, là, c'était le papa.
Le papa m'explique : « Comme tu as une bonne relation avec ma fille, est-ce que tu peux lui dire de sortir ?
Parce qu'elle ne sort jamais de la maison. » Ils vivaient vraiment dans la misère. 'Fin, ils avaient à peine un matelas pour dormir dessus.
Donc, pour le papa qui habitait près de Simony, c'était vraiment une aubaine d'avoir ce grand parc à côté. Et il voulait que sa fille sorte et sa fille ne voulait pas.
Il a dit : « Vas-y, dis à ma fille de sortir. » Et moi, en fait, j'étais plutôt à respecter les besoins de la petite.
Donc je dis au papa : « Vous savez, elle sortira quand elle le sentira. Peut-être, elle n'est pas sécurisée pour le moment.
» Et puis il m'a dit : « Mais oui, mais elle va avoir 14 ans. » Et donc là, j'ai compris en fait qu'elle avait encore quelques mois pour sortir, pour se dégourdir les jambes et qu'après, à 14 ans, elle passait à un autre
stade de sa vie, qu'elle allait être considérée autrement et qu'elle ne pourrait plus sortir-
Ouais.
Qu'accompagnée. Donc là-
C'est sombre.
C'est dur, c'est très dur. Mais bon, voilà-
Quand on est, voilà, occidental, avec des valeurs émancipatrices, avec des valeurs féministes, on a envie de se mettre en opposition à ce genre de mode de vie, ce genre de soumission, voilà.
Tu sembles dire que ta démarche, c'est plutôt neutre.
Douce.
Oui.
Pas spécialement neutre, mais douce.
D'accord.
Et, 'fin, c'est très étonnant parce que mon émotion première, c'est plutôt la colère. Mais-
Oui, on disait rebelle, tout ça.
Oui oui, c'est ça. Oui oui oui, je pratique beaucoup la colère. Mais je ne... 'Fin, je suis qui ?
'Fin, ce monsieur
a toute une vie, toutes les traditions, des coutumes. Je ne peux pas lui balancer, alors que l'objet ici, c'est les résultats de sa fille, que je suis le professeur de sa fille.
Je ne peux pas commencer à lui faire la leçon. Jamais, je ne ferais ça. Par contre, je-
C'est-à-dire que certains diraient que le rôle d'enseignant, le rôle de l'école, c'est l'émancipation, se libérer de nos racines et voilà, et proposer des valeurs féministes, anticléricales, antiracistes, voilà.
Et donc quand tu dis : « Je suis qui ? » j'ai envie de dire : « Mais tu es enseignant. »
Oui, mais mon travail avec l'élève, je le fais.
Oui.
Je ne fais que ça. Je ne fais que ça. 'Fin, je veux dire, jamais dans une confrontation agressive avec les élèves, même si ça arrive, en fait, on se prend la tête avec les élèves aussi, bien sûr.
Mais sur le moment, je ne peux pas jeter à la figure d'un parent, mais enfin-
Non, mais c'est sûr que le faire de manière agressive, ce serait de toute façon maladroit, oui.
Est-ce que la réunion de parents est vraiment le lieu opportun pour commencer à parler de ça ? Par contre, à la petite, oui, parce que cette petite, j'ai suivi toute sa scolarité et elle est,
je l'ai revue il y a une semaine.
Mais à la petite, sachant ça, en ayant entendu ça à la réunion de parents, toute l'année, j'ai été influencée par ça.
Et je pense que justement, à elle, doucement mais sûrement, je n'ai fait qu'essayer de l'éduquer à l'émancipation et à l'autonomie, à l'égalité des sexes.
Bien sûr que je l'ai fait, mais je l'ai fait avec la fille. Je l'ai pas fait avec le père.
De manière subtile.
Oui. Et en la respectant aussi, de nouveau en essayant de ne pas être dans le jugement non plus, parce que des années plus tard, donc cette fille,
voilà, cette fille a continué dans notre école, doucement aussi, mais sûrement.
Et je crois qu'elle était en troisième secondaire et elle a... ou en quatrième. Et on avait fait un spectacle de l'école et l'année d'avant, elle avait chanté.
Et moi, je coachais les chanteurs.
Hm.
Et c'était magnifique, c'était génial. On s'était déjà tellement bien entendus quand elle était dans ma classe.
On avait déjà tellement bien travaillé ensemble. C'était très gai de retravailler avec elle autour de la chanson.
Oui.
Donc voilà, c'était super chouette. L'année d'après, on a refait un spectacle. Et c'était fini, elle ne voulait plus chanter.
Et donc évidemment, j'ai été la trouver et je lui dis : « Mais enfin, viens, on y retourne, c'était tellement chouette.
Tu avais eu un succès fou. » Et elle a dit : « Non, non, non, non ». Et en fait, elle avait avancé dans sa religion.
Et donc voilà, à son degré de religion, sa manière d'interpréter sa religion, la musique-
Ouais, la danse, le chant, tout ça, ouais.
...n'est pas nécessairement la chose à faire. Mais de nouveau, à l'intérieur de moi, colère monstrueuse.
J'imagine, oui.
Mais elle fait son choix et cette fille est loin d'être bête. Donc, je lui ai dit : « Ah ». Je lui ai montré ma déception.
Je lui ai dit que je ne comprenais pas. Donc c'est pas comme si je ne disais rien, mais je vais pas la juger. Et, et voilà-
Non, bien sûr, oui.
...passons à autre chose. Et puis quand même pour terminer, parce que je suis sûre que tout le monde se demande vraiment-
Mais oui, tu l'as revue il y a une semaine.
...ce qui s'est passé, c'est que, donc, cette fille a terminé l'année passée sa rhéto chez nous. C'était la promotion la plus émouvante de ma vie,
parce que je l'ai vue arriver à douze ans et elle a terminé à vingt ans, bien, avec,
avec distinction, je ne sais plus, mais bon, en tout cas bien quoi.
Et elle nous est tombée dans les bras à moi et à ma collègue vraiment en pleurant et en disant : « Sans vous, je n'y serais jamais arrivée ».
Et quand elle dit ça, bien sûr, elle parle du français, mais elle parle aussi de tout l'aspect humain, de ce sas d'acclimatation doux,
dont elle a pu bénéficier et qui lui a aussi donné vraiment le courage de continuer parce qu'elle a dû reprendre ses études secondaires vraiment en première différenciée, puis en première secondaire, puis en deuxième.
Je crois qu'elle a doublé sa cinquième, je suis plus sûre. Enfin voilà, c'était quand même un petit peu difficile.
Et la semaine passée, donc elle est revenue toquer à la porte. Elle aime bien venir voir les photos et la classe. Et donc je lui ai demandé si je pouvais la présenter à la classe actuelle.
Et j'étais très contente et très fière de montrer aux élèves que, ben, cette élève est en première à l'ULB et a réussi tous ses examens.
Donc voilà, c'est-
Elle fait quoi comme études ?
Elle fait les langues.
Ben voilà.
Elle fait pas la danse, non.
Elle a trouvé un exemple. Et donc oui, mais c'est une très belle histoire, en tout cas en termes de, voilà, histoire humaine.
Mais voilà, mais en termes d'émancipation, si tu devais-
Mais je lui ai demandé.
Oui.
Je lui ai demandé, je lui fais : « Ah donc tu es à l'ULB, c'est super, les examens et tout ». Voilà, les questions de la prof.
C'est ça.
Et puis je lui ai dit : « Et ça va, t'es toujours avec la famille ? » Donc directement, évidemment, je m'en inquiète. « Oui, oui, je suis toujours avec la famille ».
Et je me suis surprise à lui dire : « Mais t'es pas mariée ? » Mais enfin, c'est fou parce que si j'étais restée dans mon collège traditionnel à Gembloux et que j'avais vu une fille revenir, je lui aurais dit : « Et ça va ?
T'as un amoureux ? Tu fais toujours du sport ? » Enfin, j'en sais rien. Et ici, je lui ai dit : « T'es pas mariée ou- »
Tu fais du sur-mesure quoi, oui.
Oui, mais je l'ai fait très naturellement.
C'est ça.
Et ça semble, je sais que ça doit sembler un peu fou, mais c'est, voilà, c'est... Si je lui avais dit : « T'as un amoureux ?
» Ben, elle aurait rougi. Donc, et je ne veux pas la-- Je veux respecter sa pudeur. Donc voilà, elle est toujours dans sa famille.
Il est évidemment hors de question qu'elle aille coter.
Oui, oui, c'est ça. Oui, oui, oui. Oui. Ok, oui, donc c'est vraiment toute une difficulté, mais voilà, mais on sent qu'il y a du travail, il y a, il y a-
Ben ça, c'est un-- C'est-- Enfin, on n'a pas toujours des cas aussi... On n'a pas toujours des cas comme ça hein, enfin, c'est...
Est-ce qu'il arrive parfois que pour des raisons administratives, pour des raisons, voilà, de papiers, la police passe dans les écoles d'ASPA pour-
Dans les écoles, non. Par contre, il y a des rafles dans les transports en commun hein, ça-
Oui
...ça, c'est sûr.
C'est une chose que tu as déjà vue de tes yeux ?
Non, moi, jamais, mais des collègues, oui.
D'accord.
Oui, oui. Mais voilà, dans l'école, non, les élèves sont relativement protégés.
Tu parlais de cette élève qui est arrivée à l'ULB en première pour étudier les langues. En fin de parcours, je veux dire en fin de parcours scolaire, les élèves d'ASPA en général, qu'est-ce qu'ils deviennent ?
Est-ce que vous faites un suivi de vos anciens élèves ?
On n'a pas une vue d'ensemble. On sait que nos élèves qui restent dans l'école vont dans toutes les filières professionnelles, techniques et générales et s'en sortent bien.
Pas tous, mais souvent, ils s'en sortent bien. En fait, nos élèves sont souvent motivés, donc ont plutôt bonne réputation dans l'école.
Mais les autres, ceux qui quittent l'école, on n'a pas vraiment de suivi. Mais a priori, les élèves qui arrivent scolarisés ont tout autant de chances que les autres de poursuivre ou pas des études.
Enfin, il n'y a pas vraiment une grande différence. Par contre, le public non scolarisé, le public plus fragilisé, là, c'est vraiment autre chose parce qu'il n'y a pas de place pour eux.
Il y a les DASP et puis c'est tout. Après, il n'y a pas de-- Ça n'existe pas, des classes adaptées pour ce type d'élèves jeunes.
Pour adultes, oui, il y a les associations d'alphabétisation, les formations, il y a, mais pour les adolescents, non.
Oui. On va parler un petit peu de l'actualité plus récente, puisqu'il y a eu hier au Parlement de la Fédération Wallonie-Bruxelles un vote sur un décret qui concerne directement les écoles DASP.
À l'heure actuelle, en termes de budget, il y a une enveloppe fermée pour financer les écoles DASP, donc un budget limité qui ne s'adapte pas à la demande, au nombre d'élèves.
Pourquoi est-ce que c'est comme ça à l'heure actuelle ?
Un peu parce que le gouvernement ne semble pas trouver que les migrants-
Ouais
... soient une priorité. Donc-
En tout cas, avant le vote du décret qui a eu lieu hier, oui-
Oui, voilà
...ils se sont quand même adaptés. Mais-
Ouais
...est-ce que c'est pas aussi parce que, voilà, il y a eu entre-temps une grande vague de primo-arrivants, de réfugiés qui a fait qu'ils ont un peu été obligés de l'ouvrir, cette enveloppe ?
Oui, oui, ils ont été obligés de l'ouvrir, enfin, je suppose-
Tant mieux, je réponds à la question.
Oui. Mais, enfin, clairement, cette enveloppe fermée, c'était, enfin, c'était absurde. C'était vraiment, enfin, c'était très compliqué.
Et nous, ça nous a détruit,
enfin une partie de-- on a perdu des collègues, on a perdu une classe complète, on a perdu la moitié de nos moyens en deux ans parce que cette enveloppe fermée fait qu'il y a une enveloppe pour un certain nombre de DASP.
Et s'il y a plus de DASP qui ouvrent, ben forcément, les DASP existants perdent leurs moyens. Et donc nous, vraiment, ça a eu des conséquences dramatiques.
On était vraiment arrivés à, évidemment, un confort de travail, mais à une efficacité-
Un rythme de croisière
Ah oui, vraiment, c'était hyper efficace, c'était novateur, c'était, enfin, on faisait quasiment de la recherche et tout ça a été vraiment, ben, liquidé par le fait que cette enveloppe était fermée.
Oui, oui. Cette vague de réfugiés, cette vague de primo-arrivants, suite à, voilà, la situation en Syrie, aujourd'hui, c'est terminé ? C'est-
Non, ça arrive toujours, mais un petit peu moins. Je ne connais pas les statistiques exactes, mais je pense qu'il y a, que ça s'est stabilisé.
En tout cas, il y a vraiment eu un pic en 2015 et puis ça s'est stabilisé. Je n'ai aucune idée de combien il y avait de DASP en 2015-
Oui
...puis en 2016.
Donc, on va revenir un petit peu sur ce projet de décret qui, depuis hier, est un décret voté à la quasi-unanimité par
nos parlementaires à la Fédération Wallonie-Bruxelles, décret qui se fait dans le contexte du pacte d'excellence de la ministre Marie-Martine Schyns.
Donc, il y a d'abord une redéfinition, voilà, des élèves, des enfants qui peuvent accéder aux écoles DASP, puisque c'est une liste de pays définie par l'OCDE, sur un critère socio-économique.
Ce qui fait que là où tu pouvais auparavant recevoir des élèves de toute l'Europe et de toute la planète, aujourd'hui, voilà, il y a une liste très-- plus limitée qu'auparavant.
Et donc, par exemple, tu peux toujours recevoir des élèves d'Europe centrale et orientale, mais tu ne peux plus recevoir, tu ne pourras plus recevoir bientôt des élèves italiens, portugais, espagnols.
C'est ça. Donc ça, c'est vraiment la-- avant, on arrivait-- donc il y a des primo-arrivants et puis il y a les assimilés primo-arrivants.
Et donc les assimilés primo-arrivants, enfin, ce sont les Européens,
de l'Ouest. Et depuis donc ce décret, donc l'année prochaine, quand il sera mis en place, on ne pourra plus recevoir les élèves de ces pays-là.
Et pour nous, c'est vraiment une catastrophe, une aberration.
Oui. Est-ce que-- donc voilà, je donnais tout à l'heure mon expérience avec, voilà, des jeunes élèves qui venaient d'Italie où l'intégration s'est faite assez rapidement.
Mais j'imagine que ton inquiétude, c'est plutôt au niveau des élèves qui-- qui avaient une scolarité beaucoup plus sporadique, beaucoup plus-
En fait, on trouve ça juste discriminatoire. On trouve ça juste-
Mais c'est-à-dire que si c'est au niveau socio-économique, voilà, des élèves qui ont jusque-jusque-là eu une bonne scolarité, qui viennent de pays avec des langues latines, forcément, ce sera
plus une transition plus fluide que, voilà, des gens qui viennent du Brésil.
Explique-moi la différence entre un-
Oui, non, justement pas le Brésil, oui.
Oui, non, pas justement, justement pas le Brésil. Mais explique-moi la différence entre un adolescent qui arrive d'Italie et un adolescent qui arrive de Roumanie, pour moi.
Le niveau de scolarité, peut-être.
Mais le niveau de scolarité, de notre expérience-
Ouais
...n'est pas meilleur. Enfin, on-- nos élèves italiens et nos élèves roumains, pour nous, c'est vraiment la même chose. Et les élèves espagnols aussi.
Donc, nous, on ne voit pas-
D'accord
...ce genre, on ne voit pas de différence.
C'est ça.
Et on trouve que se baser sur l'économie d'un pays, ben, c'est complètement absurde.
Donc c'est effectivement la remarque que faisait hier en séance plénière la députée Barbara Trachte à l'attention de Marie-Martine Schyns, qui, voilà, qui lui a répondu en disant : « Ben non, le seul critère,
c'est le critère socio-économique et pas le critère de la langue et pas le critère,
voilà, de la scolarité.
» Et voilà, et toi, tu m'expliquais que ça te choque complètement.
Oui, oui, c'est ça. Nous, on trouve que c'est choquant. Et d'ailleurs, son explication, je l'ai écoutée avec attention et elle était très peu convaincante.
Pour nous, se baser sur ces critères-là, ça n'a pas de sens. Pour nous, il faut se baser sur la maîtrise de la langue.
On donne comme exemple, ben, dans une même cour de récréation, il y a un Portugais et un Brésilien et les deux parlent la même langue.
Oui.
Mais quand la récréation est finie,
un retourne en deuxième secondaire où, avec vingt-huit élèves et beaucoup de cours à suivre et cinq heures de français et l'autre retourne en DASP
où il a quinze heures de français, un petit peu moins de cours et surtout plus de temps pour- Pour s'acclimater.
Et on trouve que rien que ça, c'est une injustice.
Oui. Oui, je-
Ça n'a aucun sens.
Oui, évidemment, moi, je, voilà, je suis pas un acteur de terrain. C'est vrai que, voilà, je reviens toujours avec mon expérience de ces deux élèves pour qui ça s'est très bien passé.
Mais effectivement, quand tu présentes cette dichotomie entre les Brésiliens et les Portugais pour des critères assez arbitraires, c'est un peu plus douteux.
Mais en tout cas, la conséquence que ça va avoir, c'est que nous, nous allons perdre une bonne partie de nos élèves.
Et vous allez peut-être en gagner d'autres, en... Vous allez perdre les Portugais, les Italiens, peut-être-
On est quand même-- en fait, les élèves qui arrivent chez nous, on est quand même ancrés dans un quartier, on est vraiment une école de quartier.
Et donc, les élèves qu'on a, souvent, ben donc, c'est des-- on a beaucoup de Roumains et on a beaucoup de Marocains.
On a aussi plein d'autres nationalités, mais ça, c'est quand même les, souvent les nationalités qui ressortent. Et les Marocains sont
italiens et espagnols parce que c'est leur, enfin, on est parfois leur troisième pays et ils ont acquis la nationalité d'Espagnols et d'Italiens.
Et donc tous ces élèves-là, ben, vont disparaître de nos classes pour aller dans des classes traditionnelles. Et nous, on-
D'accord, oui
...on trouve que c'est-
Ils sont, ils sont techniquement, enfin, ils sont ethniquement Marocains, mais sur le papier, ils viennent d'Italie, ils viennent du Portugal-
Voilà
...ils viennent d'Espagne, ouais.
En tout cas, ça va faire beaucoup d'économies pour cette enveloppe, évidemment.
Oui.
Parce qu'il y aura beaucoup moins d'élèves dans nos classes.
D'accord. Donc voilà. Oui, OK, oui. C'est, ben, c'est très clairement la logique derrière, hein, c'est une logique budgétaire.
C'est ce qui semble.
Voilà, en tout cas, aujourd'hui, c'est comme ça, ça vient d'être voté. Donc, on disait ouvrir l'enveloppe fermée au niveau du budget.
Donc ça, ça devrait bien vous aider, hein, puisque tu nous parlais de la situation, la détresse que vous avez connue ces dernières années.
Donc là, voilà, tu me parlais d'une classe qui a dû fermer, d'un professeur qui a dû partir.
Ben-
Du coup, tout ça, ça va revenir ?
Je ne sais pas, vu le quartier où on est situé, on va clairement perdre tous les Européens de l'Ouest. Donc, je suis pas du tout sûre qu'on va réussir à remplir nos classes.
D'accord.
Pour le moment, on a quatre classes. Je ne suis pas du tout convaincue qu'on va réussir à remplir quatre classes ou alors, on les remplira au fur et à mesure de l'année.
Donc plus-- on ne va plus travailler de la même manière. Ça, c'est sûr. Pour nous, ça va faire un grand changement.
Un autre grand changement, c'est l'allongement de la présence des élèves dans les écoles d'ASPA. Donc, tu-- on parlait tout à l'heure de dix-huit mois.
Dans certains cas, c'est douze mois, si j'ai bien compris, la durée max.
Donc en fait, nous, on plaide depuis des années pour l'allongement. Donc, comme je l'ai expliqué tout à l'heure, dix-huit mois, ben, c'est vraiment pas pratique.
Donc, on demandait l'allongement à deux ans. Il faut savoir quand même que garder un élève deux ans d'ASPA, c'est, 'fin, c'est très très rare et ça concerne des élèves très fragilisés.
Déjà, l'allongement, garder un élève dix-huit mois, sur ma carrière, on l'a fait deux fois. Ça concernait une élève syrienne et un élève roumain.
Donc comme ça, ça donne un petit peu une idée. Donc, on fait cette demande pour pouvoir organiser mieux l'accueil d'un public fragilisé.
Mais ça ne concerne pas toute une partie des élèves. Et donc, en fait, la proposition de projet, ce qu'ils nous ont proposé, a été
annoncée comme une bonne nouvelle, l'allongement à vingt-quatre mois, mais il y avait des petites notes en bas, tu vois.
Je ne les ai pas lues, donc là, tu m'apprends quelque chose.
Oui, et donc les conditions étaient une immersion progressive. Donc ce qu'ils demandaient, c'était que après huit mois d'ASPA, à raison de six heures par semaine, on intègre les élèves dans les classes normales.
Là, c'est même nos directeurs qui sont devenus fous, parce que techniquement, avec des classes bondées,
c'est impossible d'intégrer, nous, on a quarante-huit élèves, donc c'est encore plus difficile, c'est impossible d'intégrer six heures par semaine pendant les deux derniers mois de l'année, mai et juin.
C'est ce qui n'a pas beaucoup de sens non plus.
Oui, non.
C'est impossible d'intégrer autant d'élèves. Donc, cette condition mettait vraiment à mal ce projet.
'fin, c'était vraiment difficile à réaliser. Donc les directions, dès qu'on a eu vent de ce projet de décret, c'est-à-dire la semaine passée—
Vous avez publié une carte blanche dans Le Vif L'Express.
Voilà.
Vous avez, voilà, contacté un petit peu les députés et je crois qu'il y a eu un amendement, hier en séance plénière, ouais.
Et donc on a obtenu que l'immersion n'était obligatoire qu'à partir de dix mois. Donc ça veut dire à la rentrée suivante.
Donc ça, ça nous a quand même pas mal soulagés. Mais en fait, 'fin, faut pas se méprendre. Nous, on est pour l'immersion, on est contre l'obligatoire et on en revient à la rébellion du début de...
On est contre l'obligatoire.
Oui.
Pourquoi ne pas faire confiance aux gens de terrain ? 'fin, il suffit de regarder, de venir voir dans notre école, voir comme on est investis, comme on est motivés, comme on réfléchit.
Et voilà, obliger, c'est surtout ça qui nous dérange parce que de l'immersion, on la pratique déjà.
Dans le cadre du décret, il y a aussi certaines simplifications administratives et il y a aussi,
alors je ne sais absolument pas ce que ça signifie, donc tu traduiras pour moi, mais la gratuité des équivalences partielles pour les élèves qui ont suivi leur scolarité dans un pays bénéficiaire de l'aide publique au développement.
Ouais, donc ça, c'est super.
Qu'est-ce que ça veut dire ?
Alors, je t'explique. J'aurais besoin d'un tableau noir—
Oui, oui, oui.
...et des craies. Non, non. En fait, pour le moment, on a deux types d'élèves. Donc, on a les primo-arrivants et les assimilés.
Et les primo-arrivants, donc s'ils disposent de leur diplôme, ils ne... Voilà, donc si un Syrien arrive et qu'il a ses diplômes avec lui, il doit le rendre au service des équivalences.
Il doit payer cinquante euros, quelque chose comme ça, et pour faire valoir son diplôme. Mais souvent, ces élèves, quand ils arrivent, n'ont plus rien, n'ont pas de papiers, ont peu de bagages.
'fin, voilà, il est rare qu'ils aient leurs documents avec eux. Et donc, dans ces cas-là, ils bénéficient du Conseil d'intégration élargi.
Et en gros, c'est nous qui décidons. C'est nous qui décidons où les mettre. Et ça, c'est vraiment super parce que c'est...
'fin, c'est nous qui— c'est nous qu'on sait, pour parler en bon français. Mais non, mais c'est vrai, c'est...
On est les mieux placés pour les mettre, pour savoir où—
Pour savoir faire du sur-mesure.
...ils vont aller. Voilà, on sait faire du sur-mesure. Mais ça, ça concerne les primo-arrivants. Après, les assimilés, donc en fait, les Européens, eux, c'est plus compliqué.
Eux, quoi qu'il arrive, ils n'ont pas droit au Conseil d'intégration élargi et ils doivent obligatoirement introduire une demande d'équivalence, qu'ils aient ou non leurs documents.
Et cette demande d'équivalence leur coûte septante-six euros. Et même s'ils n'ont pas leur diplôme, ils doivent introduire cette équivalence, donc introduire une équivalence vide qui leur coûte cher et qui fait qu'après,
on ne sait pas du tout où ils vont aller.
Et donc il est arrivé qu'on ait des élèves italiens, italiens, qui venaient du Maroc, mais italiens quand même, qui n'avaient pas leurs documents, qui ne les ont jamais retrouvés, qui les ont perdus.
La situation familiale était très compliquée. C'était impossible pour eux de retourner en Italie. Et la fille avait terminé une troisième secondaire.
Et donc, vu sa situation administrative, elle devait recommencer une première différenciée. Donc, comme si elle n'avait pas eu son diplôme de primaire.
Et ça, c'était vraiment un grand drame. Je ne me rappelle plus de l'issue de l'histoire. Je sais que finalement, elle a pu intégrer une troisième ou quatrième secondaire, mais je ne sais pas s'ils ont retrouvé...
J'imagine qu'ils ont dû retrouver les documents, mais voilà. Et donc, en fait, nos familles arrivent souvent avec plusieurs enfants, donc, et dans une misère pas possible.
Une maman toute seule qui a fui l'Espagne parce que énormément de racisme, parce que pas de travail, arrive ici à Molenbeek.
Elle ne va pas loger au Wilton hein, 'fin.
Oui, tout à fait. Et donc, les septante-six euros, c'est beaucoup.
Trois fois septante-six euros—
Ouais.
...il faut les trouver.
C'est vrai. Donc maintenant, c'est gratuit—
Voilà.
...pour, voilà, pour en tout cas
ces pays-là. Et donc voilà, et
parallèlement à ce décret, il y a eu également, voilà, le ministre Marcourt qui a annoncé dans
la future réforme de la formation des enseignants, le fait de vouloir donner aux profs les outils pour mieux gérer les élèves allophones dans leur classe.
On ne sait pas très bien ce que ça veut dire, mais bon, ça a l'air encourageant.
Et voilà, et également, formation de base pour le français langue étrangère à tous les enseignants, plus une option allant jusqu'à trente crédits pour ceux qui veulent se spécialiser.
Donc, probablement des enseignants mieux formés au français langue étrangère, qui risquent d'arriver dans ton établissement d'ici dix ans.
Ben oui, en fait, ben, pour entendre les bruits de couloir, parce que je ne mène pas tous, je ne suis pas tous les décrets, mais—
Je fais seulement semblant.
Pour entendre les bruits de couloir de mes collègues de la haute école, ben ça semble compliqué. C'est, de nouveau, c'est très compliqué à mettre en place, en fait.
Ce qu'ils proposent est très compliqué à mettre en place. Donc tout le monde n'est pas, ne saute pas de joie.
Mais bien sûr, quand tu le lis comme ça, ben il est évident qu'il faut des professeurs mieux formés et prêts à recevoir et à enseigner à ce type d'élèves.
Moi, OK, ça me semble évident. Quelque chose qui me semble vraiment important, c'est de revaloriser la fonction de prof, parce que, ben on est vraiment peu considérés, on pourrait dire poliment.
Avant l'interview, tu me disais : "Les profs sont considérés comme des merdes."
Ah oui, oui, oui, oui, oui. Oh oui, c'est vraiment, c'est... Les gens sont—
Comment est-ce que tu le ressens, ça, au quotidien ? T'sais, quand tu dis que t'es prof, les gens changent de trottoir ?
Non, les gens changent pas de trottoir, mais les blagues sur la tranquillité du job, sur les vacances.
Oui, les fonctionnaires, tout ça.
Et puis il faut pas le prendre mal, hein, ça va, je te charrie, mais bon, quand même, t'as des congés. Ben oui, 'fin...
Oui, après, ben moi, j'ai trouvé un petit peu la parade quand les gens me disent : "Mais oui, mais t'es prof", l'air de dire : "C'est pas compliqué."
Ben tu leur dis : "Fais-le, alors", hein. Si t'as envie d'avoir— parce que c'est vrai qu'on a une qualité de vie grâce aux congés et aux horaires, non négligeable.
Mais vas-y, fais-le, d'être en classe, avec des ados, avec des enfants, avec des tout-petits. Ben voilà, il faut quand même savoir le faire.
Bref, donc l'idée de passer à quatre ans, ben va déjà peut-être un petit peu changer les mentalités parce que y a rien à faire.
Moi, je ne suis qu'une régente et ça, je le sens aussi de moins en moins, mais—
Qu'est-ce que ça signifie exactement une régente ?
Oh ben, une régente, ça signifie que j'ai pas fait l'université. Donc—
D'accord.
...j'ai fait un régendat et donc j'ai fait trois ans d'études—
Oui.
...et pas quatre ou cinq ans.
Quand tu dis aux gens que tu es prof, les gens ne savent pas, si tu as été à l'université, si tu es régente—
Non, mais—
...si tu as fait une agrégation.
...la plupart des gens savent quand même que si tu donnes cours dans les plus petites classes—
C'est ça.
...tu es régente et dans les plus grandes classes, tu es licenciée, donc tu as un master.
Mmm-hmm.
Bon, il se fait que moi, je donne cours dans des classes spéciales. Donc voilà, on est—
Ça change la donne.
Voilà, ça change la donne. Mais quand même, moi, je suis payée, je suis moins payée que—
Oui.
...que mes collègues qui ont un master. Et donc en fait, d'allonger les études, de les rendre plus fournies, 'fin, de les élargir, ben je pense que ça pourrait revaloriser la fonction de prof.
Je crois que c'est très naïf.
Ouais. Oh là là.
Je vois tes yeux, je crois que tu ne penses pas du tout ce que tu dis.
Je sais pas. On verra, j'espère. J'espère, mais c'est parce qu'on est quand même maltraités, donc voilà.
Maltraités ? Au niveau salarial et au niveau—
Rien que quand tu dis, selon je sais plus quel critère les élèves sont—
Oui, l'OCDE, ouais.
...voilà, selon l'OCDE, les élèves sont, c'est les élèves belges qui apprennent le moins. C'est dur—
Non, pas qui apprennent le moins, qui aiment le moins aller à l'école.
Qui aiment le moins aller à l'école, mais nos résultats comparés aux autres pays—
Oui, oui, aussi les tests PISA, tout ça.
...voilà, sont très mauvais. Et donc voilà, c'est très dur en fait, parce que de faire le constat que l'enseignement n'est pas adapté aux élèves, aux besoins des élèves—
Mmm-hmm.
...qu'il y a une espèce de, ben de fossé entre les deux et qu'on comprend pas, on jette pas les bons ponts—
C'est, alors, bon, c'est très anecdotique, ce que je vais dire, mais, donc, tu parlais de ton expérience comme enseignant à Gembloux, comme élève moyenne, tu disais.
Mmm-hmm.
J'étais moi-même un élève plus que moyen, hein, donc j'ai jamais raconté dans le podcast, ça, mais—
Vas-y, raconte, sens-toi à l'aise.
Oui, oui, on a le temps. Quand j'ai terminé ma rhéto, j'avais une seconde session que je n'ai pas passée.
Enfin, que j'ai passé les examens, mais je n'ai pas réussi. Et donc on m'a gentiment expliqué que voilà, je n'allais pas recevoir mon diplôme.
Et ce que j'ai fait à ce moment-là, c'est que j'ai contacté un pote qui avait un père avocat et qui avait fait un recours externe un an avant.
Et je lui ai demandé de me forwarder, voilà, ce PDF de dix pages ou je sais plus quoi. Et donc j'ai pris la lettre, j'ai changé les noms, j'ai changé les mots, j'ai changé les chiffres, voilà.
Mais c'était vraiment très verbeux, c'était très lawyerish, très avocat, très énervé comme ça.
Ouais.
Et puis j'ai fait signer à mon papa.
En mettant la nappe dessus ou il savait ce qu'il signait ?
Non, bien sûr, il savait ce qu'il signait hein. Puis, genre, c'était le dernier jour pour la date limite. Alors genre, je sais pas pourquoi j'ai attendu aussi longtemps.
Ça explique pourquoi je réussissais pas mes examens, mais j'ai attendu le dernier jour pour envoyer cette lettre, ce recours externe.
J'ai pris mon vélo jusqu'à Molenbeek, j'ai traversé le canal, j'ai— tout le monde était parti. Il restait le staff de sécurité.
J'ai donné la lettre au staff de sécurité en disant : "Est-ce que vous pouvez me donner un reçu ?" "Non." Donc, je suis rentré chez moi, voilà.
Et bon ensuite, je suis allé dans une école absolument infernale que j'ai absolument détestée, c'était un internat à Floreffe.
Ah oui.
Voilà, oui.
On le connaît.
C'est l'enfer. Et genre, trois semaines après, voilà, je reçois un SMS : "Ah tiens, ton recours est passé." Voilà, donc c'est comme ça que j'ai eu mon diplôme.
Et donc, voilà, j'étais assez moyen, voire mauvais selon les cours. Mais ce dont je me souviens très bien quand j'étais élève en secondaire, c'était que toute la culpabilité était mise sur mes épaules.
Oui.
Qu'il y avait aucune remise en question de la part du staff, de la part de l'école, de la direction.
Non, non.
C'était, j'étais le vilain petit canard. C'est quoi ? C'est...
Les profs qui ne veulent jamais se remettre en question.
Oui.
Ben oui, donc le pacte d'excellence cherche, 'fin tend vers un enseignement de meilleure qualité.
Et bien sûr que je comprends ton sentiment en tant qu'élève, j'aurais bien voulu aussi me sentir moins inadaptée au système scolaire.
Bien sûr que j'aurais voulu ça. Donc, on est pour, 'fin, en tout cas, moi et les personnes avec qui je travaille, on est pour la réflexion, la remise en question, le,
remodeler ce qui existe, bien sûr qu'on est pour ça.
Je ne connais pas toutes les écoles, bien sûr, mais de mon expérience de prof à Bruxelles, il y a vraiment de nombreux projets qui tendent vers donner,
donner une place différente à l'élève et surtout essayer d'avoir un enseignement adapté à chaque élève.
On le disait donc, pour les auditeurs qui n'ont pas suivi, tu es prof de français langue étrangère, dans un établissement d'ASPA.
En plus de ça, quand tu rentres chez toi le soir, tu écris aussi des livres pour enfants. Tu fais ça avec ton compagnon qui est illustrateur.
Est-ce que tu peux nous parler un petit peu de ta démarche, voilà, d'auteure ? Comment est-ce que ça t'est venue cette idée d'écrire des livres pour enfants ?
Eh bien, en fait,
moi, j'écris depuis quasiment toujours, 'fin depuis l'adolescence, en tout cas, je tiens un journal intime,
quand j'étais adolescente, j'ai transformé mes tourments d'adolescence et mes idées noires en poèmes, en pièces de théâtre—
D'accord. Très mélodramatique.
Oui, bien sûr, en début de roman et en multiples débuts de romans, jamais en fin de roman.
Mais donc voilà, j'ai toujours bien aimé écrire et, arrivée à l'âge adulte aussi, j'écrivais surtout des choses basées sur,
sur moi, sur ma vie, sur ce que je vivais,
notamment une petite chronique qui s'appelait La palpitante vie sentimentale de Charles.
C'était très rigolo. Mais voilà, donc, j'écrivais vraiment juste pour sortir des choses de moi, vraiment, c'était une nécessité.
Ça a toujours été une nécessité. Et, en 2008, j'ai rencontré Ian De Haas, qui est devenu, ben mon amoureux.
Et lui était libraire spécialisé en littérature jeunesse et artiste-peintre. Et donc, en fait, tout ça combiné, il m'a vraiment donné le goût à la littérature jeunesse.
Donc, on n'avait pas du tout encore d'enfants à ce moment-là. Donc c'est vraiment l'envie qui est venue juste en voyant les livres.
Et donc à nous deux, parce que lui avait vraiment très envie de faire un album jeunesse, mais ne trouvait pas les mots, n'avait pas spécialement la structure.
Et en fait, moi, parce que j'avais toujours beaucoup écrit et peut-être avec ma formation aussi, j'avais cette structure.
Et donc, en fait, très vite, je-- 'fin quand j'écris, ça sort très vite. C'est assez expéditif.
Condamné ?
Ah oui, oui, c'est très, c'est vraiment expéditif.
Tu dis que tu écris, je sais pas, de ton expérience, de ton vécu et qui-- donc y a beaucoup de toi dans-
Oh plus maintenant. Plus maintenant.
Ce que j'allais dire que tu as publié, J'ai perdu ma pantoufle de...
Ouais, ça, c'était vraiment de moi.
Ah tu as vraiment perdu ta pantoufle.
C'était le premier. On dit toujours que la première œuvre d'un réalisateur ou d'un auteur ou d'une autrice, elle part de son vécu.
Et oui, oui, cette petite fille de J'ai perdu ma pantoufle s'appelle Maya. Et ça, c'était vraiment de moi. Après, oui, on part du quotidien, mais de nos enfants, mais pas que.
Parfois, on part d'idées beaucoup plus abstraites, plus universelles et on les décline en histoires. Donc voilà.
Et J'ai perdu ma pantoufle. J'ai proposé cette histoire à Yann, qui l'a illustrée. On en a fait un joli petit objet livre qu'on a bricolé nous-mêmes.
Et après quelques refus, on a été acceptés chez Alice Éditions, qui est une maison d'édition belge super chouette et qui est bien en vue. Donc...
J'ai,
j'ai moi-même des petits neveux et des fois, on lit des livres pour enfants ensemble. Et c'est intéressant de voir à quel point y a des choses qui transparaissent, des,
des piliers culturels, des choses comme, voilà, la princesse qu'il faut aller sauver, la maman qui fait les courses, des choses comme ça.
hein, y avait-- je lisais avec lui un livre où un papa et un petit garçon vont faire la course, donc sans la maman.
Mais le papa est très distrait, il oublie tout et c'est la maman qui a un petit peu la charge mentale et qui doit aller-
Ouais.
Qui dit : Ah mais non, tu as oublié la liste des courses. Ah mais non, tu as oublié le portefeuille. Ah heureusement que maman est là.
Oui, mais là, nous, on s'en donne à cœur joie. Et là, y a plus de douceur et de...
'fin si, la douceur, mais je veux dire, c'est pas comme avec mes élèves. Ici, dans nos livres-
Là, tu vas frontal.
Là, on mène le combat, bien sûr. Et je dis nous parce que Yann est aussi engagé que moi. Mais oui, bien sûr, je pense à quand on doit donner vie à un personnage.
Donc souvent, hein, comme on fonctionne avec Yann, moi, j'écris le texte et puis après, ben
le personnage naît physiquement sous son crayon, et il faut décider comment il est, s'il est grand, s'il est gros, quelle couleur aura sa peau, comment sont ses cheveux.
Et en fait, on s'est rendu compte grâce à des amis, mais aussi grâce à l'expérience de Yann quand il était libraire, que les petits garçons et les petites filles qui n'ont pas la peau beige sont très peu représentés.
Et donc ça, c'est devenu quelque chose de fort important pour nous. Et à ce moment-là, Yann était en train d'écrire une histoire qui s'appelait Super Lumineuse et qui est sortie chez Alice Éditions en septembre passé.
Et ça nous a semblé évident que cette petite fille devait avoir la peau brune. Et voilà, ça, c'est une manière pour nous de nous engager.
Et en séance de dédicace, les retours sont réels et très positifs. Il y a vraiment des parents qui viennent et qui font : Ah, c'est super.
Et parce que la petite s'appelle Nour aussi. Et en fait, rien que de prendre un prénom arabe, de donner un type africain à la petite fille, ben ça ouvre vraiment et les parents sont super contents.
Donc voilà, ça, c'est une des manières de bousculer un petit peu les codes. Il y en a plein d'autres.
Et donc, est-ce que, je dis ça en rigolant un petit peu, mais est-ce que, dans J'ai perdu ma pantoufle, est-ce qu'il y a une démarche féministe ?
Ah, des trucs cachés. Non, il n'y a pas de démarche... 'fin, en tout cas, je n'ai pas réfléchi à une démarche féministe en écrivant J'ai perdu ma pantoufle. Non.
Non ? Ben, j'en vois un autre ici qui s'appelle Saint-Nicolas, c'est qui celui-là ?
Ouais.
Donc là, là clairement, on touche un peu plus religieux ou culturel.
Il est super celui-là. J'adore. Je te jure, il est super.
C'est très objectif. Qu'est-ce que... Oui, ben donc, qu'est-ce que... Je suis certain qu'il y a des choses à raconter à ce niveau-là en termes de-
Oui oui oui. Ben nous, enfin, Yann et moi, on avait vraiment envie de se frotter, de se frotter à la légende de Saint Nicolas.
Les éditeurs n'étaient pas du tout chauds, parce que c'est très saisonnier. Donc il a fallu attendre plusieurs livres et qu'on ait un petit peu de succès pour qu'il y ait la confiance.
Et en fait, dans cette histoire de Saint Nicolas, ben pour moi, la tradition de Saint Nicolas est belle pour plein de raisons, parce que ça fait rêver.
Père Fouettard, tout ça.
Oui, Père Fouettard aussi, fait rêver.
Ouais.
Et c'était-- Il y avait des sujets polémiques. Donc-
Père Fouettard, tout ça.
Père Fouettard, tout ça, la croix sur la mitre et tout. Ah, je peux dire qu'on nous a embêtés avec cette croix. Et donc, on décide de se lancer dans l'aventure de Saint Nicolas.
Il n'y a pas de croix sur la couverture.
Non, mais il n'y a pas de croix du tout. Et on se renseigne. On a vraiment travaillé notre sujet et puis après, il a fallu faire des choix.
Et donc, bien sûr, il y a la polémique de Père Fouettard. Bien sûr que pour nous, Père Fouettard,
comme certains le représentent, donc avec des boucles d'oreilles en or, voilà, des black faces, des grosses lèvres, enfin une perruque de cheveux bouclés.
Pour nous, ben c'est juste le symbole de tout ce qu'on déteste.
J'ai connu ça à l'école, moi, ouais.
Bien sûr, nos filles connaissent encore ça à l'école hein. Donc ces choses sont très très présentes. Et donc nous, on a fait le choix de faire un Père Fouettard sale.
Et donc parce qu'il va dans la cheminée, voilà. Et légèrement androgyne aussi, parce qu'on ne sait pas vraiment si c'est un garçon, si c'est une fille.
Ouais, c'est intéressant.
Donc voilà, ça, c'est pour la polémique du Père Fouettard. Et concernant la polémique de la croix, parce que c'est l'année où on l'a sorti, c'était surtout un problème de croix.
Yann, pour dessiner le costume de Saint Nicolas, a fait référence à des costumes d'évêques réels. Et si tu regardes les costumes d'évêques, tous n'ont pas la croix.
Donc la tradition est respectée parce qu'il y a une mitre, une crosse, une cape.
De la façon dont tu en parles, on dirait qu'il y a eu un backlash. Il y a eu-
Ben disons qu'en séance de dédicace, on a eu quelques vieilles pas contentes quoi.
C'est peut-être pas le public cible.
Voilà. Quoique les mamies...
C'est vrai. Très bien, c'est magnifique. Dans quelques semaines, tu vas en publier un nouveau qui parle justement ben de ton domaine à toi, l'accueil des migrants.
Est-ce que tu peux nous en dire un peu plus ?
Oui. Ben donc en fait, ça s'appelle Brady et Thomas. Le livre n'est pas illustré par Yann, mais par un autre illustrateur qui s'appelle Philippe Dekemeter, qui est super aussi.
C'est tout à fait objectif. Et voilà, donc ça s'appelle Brady et Thomas, qui sont les prénoms des deux personnages principaux.
Et en fait, de nouveau, ici, j'avais vraiment envie de parler, de raconter une histoire qui parlait des points de vue.
Et je voulais faire passer... Enfin, ce que je voulais expliquer, c'est qu'on peut vivre une situation, mais ne pas la vivre de la même manière que l'autre.
Et mon message, c'était qu'avec de l'attention, de l'intérêt et un petit peu d'ouverture aux autres, il y avait vraiment moyen de comprendre comment les autres pouvaient vivre leur situation.
C'était ce message un petit peu plus universel que j'avais envie de raconter et je l'ai inscrit dans quelque chose que je connais mieux, c'est-à-dire ben les migrants, mais ça aurait pu se passer dans un autre décor de nouveau.
Ici, en l'occurrence, ça se passe dans un pays en paix où une famille accueille des réfugiés de guerre.
Et le petit garçon qui fait partie de la famille qui accueille, on ne lui a pas bien expliqué le truc et il est vraiment chamboulé dans ses habitudes.
Par exemple, son cartable préféré, ben on lui en achète un nouveau et on donne son cartable préféré qui est un peu déchiré à l'autre.
Et donc, ben lui, il est dégoûté, il s'en fiche d'avoir un nouveau cartable. C'était son cartable préféré. Et l'autre, il ne comprend pas du tout pourquoi on lui refile les objets usagés d'un autre garçon.
Donc chacun vit la situation avec son propre point de vue. Et ben l'idée, c'est qu'ils vont arriver à s'ouvrir, à communiquer à leur manière.
Et voilà. J'avais vraiment envie de faire passer un message d'ouverture.
Donc ça sort chez Alice Éditions dans quelques semaines.
On sera à la Foire du livre, en tout cas.
Super, très bien. Chers auditeurs, si ça vous intéresse, Charlotte Bellière chez Alice Éditions, au Salon du livre, donc dans quelques semaines.
Charlotte Bellière, merci beaucoup.
Ben de rien. Merci.
On a passé septante minutes très intéressantes. Et chers auditeurs, à dans deux semaines. Au revoir. Et voilà, c'est déjà tout pour cet épisode.
Quelques clarifications à présent. À plusieurs moments dans le podcast, je cite la députée Barbara Trachte, qui avait dit la veille au Parlement que les élèves belges sont ceux qui aiment le moins aller à l'école de tous les pays de l'OCDE.
Après quelques recherches, il s'avère que c'est seulement à moitié vrai. En vérité, il s'agit d'une étude menée non pas par l'OCDE, mais par le HBSC, en collaboration avec l'OMS.
Et la liste des pays concernés n'est pas la même, puisqu'on parle surtout des pays européens. Et deuxième chose, dans ce classement, la Belgique est divisée en deux : la Flandre et la Fédération Wallonie-Bruxelles.
Et c'est vrai que la Belgique francophone arrive dernière sur les quarante-deux régions en ce qui concerne les jeunes de quinze ans, puisque seulement 4 % d'entre eux disent qu'ils aiment l'école.
La Flandre, par contre, n'a pas ce problème. Bref, c'est une étude, ça ne concerne pas la plupart des Belges et c'est à prendre avec des pincettes.
Je mets le lien dans la description. Voilà, maintenant que tout ça est clarifié, je tenais à remercier très chaleureusement Myriam Leroy de m'avoir mis en contact avec Charlotte.
Je l'ai dit en début d'épisode, mais j'ai beaucoup aimé m'entretenir septante minutes avec elle. Et si tout se passe bien, il se pourrait qu'on refasse quelque chose ensemble.
Je vous tiendrai au courant de tout ça sur Facebook et Twitter. Tous les liens sont dans la description.
Et pour ne pas manquer le prochain épisode avec Rudy Lionet, s'il vous plaît, n'oubliez pas de vous abonner au podcast sur votre plateforme de podcast préférée.
Allez, à dans deux semaines. Bye bye.